that's fun to make sure
i'm here nice to meet some of you and
also talk to you
some of you thank you uh can't wait to
email you
karen you may know you may not know
dixon and dave
is that correct i think you know
everybody else uh i think so
yeah what's up y'all hi howdy hey
carrie i hope you're doing hopped up on
caffeine let's go
oh yeah i had a big old monster i'm
ready i met dave at rtx
london we were very good that was years
ago yeah
that was a long time ago how are you
doing man i'm good andy how are you
doing
i'm okay i'm okay i'm hanging in there
i'm hanging in there in these coveted
times
yeah we uh we played we played hide and
go seek last night on alfredo's stream
and it was [ __ ] awesome so we should
play that today
whenever i watch any of my friends do
like i did come in and watch a little
bit of that i think i think in fredo
stream like whenever i watch people do
those alternate rules ones that are that
extensive i just get stressed out
like i don't it just seems like it is
stressful
it turns it into a horror game 100 you
you get stressed out when you're
playing the normal rules and you're just
yeah i can't say that that is true being
the imposter is
my least favorite uh and i figured out a
way i haven't done it for this stream
but that i can hook up a heart rate
monitor
uh it like doubles when i'm the imposter
oh yeah
oh it's it's so nice i i like i went i
went to the restroom earlier and i
almost like wanted to vomit knowing that
i had to be the imposter coming up
i did upload uh uh uh one of the rounds
that we did
it was where it was uh andy it was you
and bruce and me were all the imposters
and we won
but annie you and i had made some real
[ __ ] stupid decisions the whole game
bruce didn't
but you and i i was like i don't know
how we won this like it was really bad
across the board yeah we killed some
people but it was [ __ ] stupid
alana remember the time that i like
ratted you out that was the round that i
uploaded fan
yeah yeah it was that one but there were
also moments in it where like i didn't
kill someone because i guess i didn't
know that if the amount of
crewmates and impulses were equal then
we would have just won i thought that
they had to be like
an extra person needed to die so yeah i
could have just killed someone and it
would have been done but i didn't
realize
it was just stupid across the board it
was not like i was just i was so i was
just so mad but not really at lana just
had myself mostly for just like not
feeling comfortable in that situation
and there was two people in a room
and me and alana were in the room both
the killers and i went for the kill
and then alana didn't go for the other
kill it's when i i had started to walk
out
i was leaving the room when you killed
so i didn't know what was going on
i should have seen it i should have
known but you also shouldn't have
executed the strategy
like okay you're right [ __ ] i thought
somebody's gonna go for a double kill
and i just rat it out
like i really hope i have a telekinetic
you know connection with my
monster and we go for the kill just
gotta dance back and forth
mm-hmm and then the signal right like
chad is telling you how bad you are at
the game is
like [ __ ] i know yeah that happens
well chad's you know the best part i was
thinking about this yesterday chat can't
backseat you in this game and i'll tell
you why
oh they try and because well no they
definitely try but they can't and i'll
tell you what
andy how long have you and i known each
other
um like four or five four yeah four five
years right
yeah uh i've known uh addiction a little
while now john
about five six years know carrie for a
long time knowlana for a long time
alfredo for a long time they can't tell
me
what my relationship is with you guys so
they don't trust me they don't know but
i may know you guys are lying because of
blank blankets
i know each other yeah yeah yeah we know
each other so
chair so chat can't back they can't they
they physically can't and if they do
ban them
that's when we just ban a [ __ ] no i
think the backseat gaming with this game
is
really bad and people will say [ __ ] like
why didn't you kill someone there
because they've just jumped in and not
realized that like one person over in
the next room was there like it's just
they just give you a lot of advice that
you're like there was someone literally
right there what do you mean guys
the average chap 500 iq
brain pulsing
oh man all right kraken is the last one
in i think
he is muted so when he on on mutes we
can play
is barley um
he can uh why i mean he's always the
imposter yeah we want we want someone
that's always the imposter to be here
well you know i'm here for you andy i'll
i'll i'll shout you out
are we playing europe you should get
blaine does blaine want to play i would
love to have blaine
i'll i'll text him yeah if he wants to
if he wants to uh
shoot him a text and see and then if he
does we'll just invite him to discord
i'll never forget i'll never forget the
whole like the first time i experienced
the idea of having
visual tasks in this game and me
yeah and farley was like well andy was
in weapons and he he wasn't shooting
missiles like yeah was it those 20 guns
i'll shoot them because like yeah
we're hiring i was like okay well yeah
i i remember seeing someone who
didn't know that only imposters had
vents being like well then i jumped out
of the vent and he was right there and
you're like well
but you really don't [ __ ] yourself on
that one last week i vented right in
front of autumn and it was her first
game and she didn't smells great
yeah it happened that happened
it happens it happens to me all the time
actually i've had people die in the room
that i'm in and i didn't see it
yeah my chat will flip out and i'll i'll
see like blank vented and i don't see
their name so i don't want to look at
chat anymore cause i don't wanna i don't
want to spoil my game i don't know
yeah i don't i don't let jet dictate
like i just if they're if they see
something that i don't it's cheating if
i
go by their word and like true i have
asked them for help before i have been
like please chat
what happened i missed it but i probably
you probably shouldn't do that
that's not it should probably stop doing
that about meta gaming
hell yeah man check the [ __ ] right off
nice alfredo get him
i'm not listening to you rahul just came
in my chat and said thanks for the
invite
uh someone also said it's going to be
awkward with alana's ex here that's not
a thing that's not a thing
nobody needs to worry about that being a
thing because it's not
yeah not even by the way
i've been riding around with this a
number of times he is more than welcome
to join
anytime anytime rahul could jump into
discord
at any time during any stream he could
play any game with me
i feel like that's a [ __ ] open that's
better than any of us get treated
yeah [ __ ] hey drew wow he's already got
an advantage
alana you are more here's here's the
list of people that are always more than
welcome alfredo
oh damn it that's it
uh john reinstinger carrie sounds like
yeah yeah bria
andy i guess i don't know why you said
that
dave not so much uh
you're on my level it's all right
you guys could anybody could do that
that's the thing is actually recently in
the last few weeks i've been trying to
get among us together alana knows
she's on a text chain where i text
everybody and go hey you want to play
and they'll go yeah and then everybody
cancels on me uh
hours before so then how did you put
this together bruce
did we all cancel on you today no right
yeah
we had three or four people cancelled on
me all right
well the rest of us are here and we're
ready to murder yeah i messaged people
because i knew other people would cancel
that's bad
that's crazy it might be super quiet but
what list
am i a part of because i just joined and
i'm not sure if i should be worried
oh you're part of the coolest andy you
made the cut fbi most
watchers yeah you're always on my list
you know that you made that
you're you're on the good list yeah
oh my god that's true and i think you
remember that night really well but i
remember being terrified and so scared
because i was all alone and you were
there and i was like oh my god okay
please diction save me from the darkness
i don't think you realize how terrifying
it was to be alone in a city
as a woman i thought you guys were all
in love terrifying
i thought you guys are going to love me
don't worry i'll protect you addiction
okay
we're waiting for some people waiting
for you guys so that's awkward
well you were
i'm just deflecting dude i'm just i'm
trying not to get i'm not i'm trying to
throw the heat off that's pretty [ __ ]
sucks vote him out vote him out vote him
out
don't show that hey are we i saw him
unwise he's good
he got body scanned
not showing don't worry i'm not sure
i just wanted to know if if i was
playing or not i didn't know what was
going on
melatonin betrayed me get in here oh
okay i'm gonna finish it i'm putting on
makeup so i look like
a ghost because i'm already on makeup
who just yelled get in
i didn't know i was playing until about
a few minutes ago
so i'm gonna finish my face okay
right there okay one game one game make
sure it's not kraken
no double kills okay go real slow guys
okay like basically do it where alana's
the only killer and no one else kills
and then she hates it
i never forgive you no you did you did
do good work after i died you did you
put in here
i was proud of you okay yeah i was
trying to warm up i was i was like
scared of people oh settings are good to
hear for everybody yeah can anyone give
me a tip on how to like get discord
overlay to show up on my obs
i can see it but stream can't see it
yeah okay
i'm gonna have to display capture yeah
you have to have oh it really works for
game capture on me but
the post display capture would work
there's a thing called discord stream
kit
oh i'd have to download it i just did it
i just put i'd put the link in the
description okay i'll have to get that
for real this is
if you're using game capture you could
just right click and do like enable
third-party overlays
okay let's try that and it will pop up
that's like a quick kick
voice widget voicemail yeah voice
switching
capture third party
yeah yeah are you is everybody ready
yeah yeah that's fine yeah uh brie is
the
she's putting on her face so let's go
okay for what
wait what are we playing right what
don't silence sideshame
just oh yeah uh yeah regular
okay
all right off to a great start everyone
i'm not the imposter which is my
favorite way to play this [ __ ] game
so really happy about it
let's do it let's just roll andy andy
mandy little [ __ ] bag
as it turns out andy knots us
confirmed andy knots us
um okay
oh wait wait wait wait there's one in
here that i have to go to
let's do this all right all right all
right all right zero
don't you [ __ ] kill me the jon don't
you [ __ ] kill me bro
you get away from me you son of a [ __ ]
all right all right all right
okay like look the thing that clears
andy that fast is that i know
he doesn't have that kind of galaxy
brain
where this game is concerned
oh no already uh yeah that was in
uh top of electrical like the deepest
part of electrical
oh yeah that's a killing trend yeah i
found it
uh anyone else in there i s
well i just seen criken kind of in that
area i had two
i had two i'm not not implicating kraken
same same it's still really very very
far right i saw a phrase
yeah andy i've cleared you i've decided
i trust you you're
okay you're the imposter what
yeah i uh i passed you walking into
electrical
and then uh addiction followed right
after you and then
bruce went in and apparently didn't see
you so
i went i went west after that whatever
cause the
oxygen finished up so i went back to the
like a round to go back up to mid bay
oh i couldn't see you that was very
self-reported but franken could be lying
here
breaking could be lying it's true
because we saw a cricket milling around
storage
really everyone
defense
stop killing people okay well someone
just keep an eye out
on my new friend k-town and bruce
because
like i said keep an eye on cracking
everybody uh cracking around doing weird
stuff
that's pretty suspicious that's pretty
[ __ ] sustained yeah but what was
alfredo doing this whole time
keep an eye on fredo
okay i'm gonna go
to like o2 i don't trust john your
[ __ ] sauce bro
what are you chasing me for
i don't know what the the timer is so i
have you know got problems with that
obviously
it's very satisfying great done
cool
see i feel like if john were planning to
kill me he would have just killed me now
right like i'd be i'd be dead
if that were the plan oh my gosh freda
freda
dave dave everybody what are y'all doing
afraid of [ __ ] off
what's everybody doing in here
yeah yeah now that checks out i all just
um
really really left and
he was gonna let it timeout uh i really
should have seen that coming
he was absolutely gonna let it time out
that's why i had to do it
okay so i don't know where that body was
the body was hidden but it was in
communications
and it's alana wait did you stuff did
you report it
no yeah i reported it but i had the
report button light up but i don't know
where the body is you see what i'm
saying
i'm gonna so i'm gonna put out like a
juicy detail here i was an admin
i was looking at the map i saw two in
columns
and then the report instantly came up
okay that sounds like a self-report then
my man you know what i'm saying
uh it's not a self-report um because
again
i walked in and told you i couldn't find
the body but the report button light it
up
so i'll just manage your perspective
recently
i'll sit i don't know yet so i walked in
was going to do my task communications
because i had the upload task
and uh i saw the report button light up
so that that's
odd so i walked out walked back in and
it lit up again so i reported because
that's what you do when there's a body
it was k-town
i mean the map had two two impulses i
believe and then
even before i saw one drop on the map it
was reported
it went from two to reported that's what
the map said
how about we put on our paper hats
here where was k-town during all this
where was k-town that's right i was in
electrical with bruce
and then i walked to the left and then
he uh carrie walked by me in the bottom
and then i went to go do the simon says
[ __ ] on the far left
and that's the only time i saw k-town
yeah i see
people in the room who would have helped
out with comms like i was
there doing the thing which i did it up
and then i went up to the
top you should right should have left
columns and scenes
because offerings
good luck losing guys i'm a follower i'm
[Music]
how wrong he was addiction you're still
here you got it you gotta deafen
wait are you also dead i'm dead oh okay
uh who killed you one who killed you
yeah cape town hate down stab the [ __ ]
out of me
is k-town the only um imposter
i have no idea i just know that he
killed me yeah also killed me
a great opportunity to vote him out in
that first meeting but you didn't
i know i oh bruce is dead oh that's
right nope never mind disregard brothers
hey bruce oh yeah yeah k-town is [ __ ]
okay don't come with us carrie oh oh is
it cape town oh yeah yeah yeah
i don't know if it's cracking if
cricket's playing third impossible right
now but
there are two right there are two so i i
like crack it's been weird the entire
time but i i think he's going
super crazy also just a weird guy you
know
i think it's kraken i'm pretty sure it's
kraken and cape town oh maybe not
well k-town killed both oh john just got
killed oh and like
i didn't see him coming someone just
smashed him too hard i think
yeah yeah he's sure looking too hard
currently
yeah that's what i thought wow andy
nice job cracking
and then you turned it back on me that
was awesome
i didn't turn anything back on you i
voted for you at the very end because
you voted for me two [ __ ] rounds in a
row dude
you're always voting for gamer carrie
you're a [ __ ] gamer the thing that
got me with carrie
is that we were both in the room uh
fixing the thing
loads of people came in everyone left
with carrie and i still left in the room
and then i was dead but nobody
remembered leaving me alone with carrie
nope there's a whole squad of people
came in we're like well they seem to be
doing it and then just pieced out and i
was like guys
you didn't remember served him up on a
silver platter in that first meeting and
no one
i know andy did you kill
kerry had three kills
i literally the first round i saw carrie
i told everyone and then bruce is like
it's probably kraken and i said what
what
and that's what you became
what you were being sus dude
all right i was so wrong about andy holy
[ __ ] i really i [ __ ] trusted that
dude
i really thought he was good that's what
i get for trusting andy cortez man
i should have known i shouldn't know
somebody better be going to do the other
one you [ __ ] [ __ ] john get away
from me
john john john
i'm gonna i'm gonna die you know oh
he's walking away well that's nice
okay there's three that's good i like
that don't [ __ ] turn around john i
will [ __ ] you up
not that i have the ability to do that
but i would love to
oh [ __ ] uh i i don't remember how to do
this
is that we need to loop around the admin
and i don't remember how to open doors
there we go okay you know in the other
one you can press to open them but in
this instance
i do not know i think you should have to
wait
all right
[Music]
you [ __ ] kill me carrie i swear to
god oh
all right hello um i have found a body
an electrical and i didn't see anyone go
in or out or anything so that's all i
got
brilliant anyone being sauce
i am i am we had a real me and andy had
a real
awkward moment when we were trapped in
the hallways
i caught a glimpse of that on the other
side i was watching andy because i was
sure someone was going to kill him
there was a there's a full 10 seconds
where either of us could have killed
each other in that hallway
and no one would have seen a thing so
which which all the time
the one outside admin the doors the one
that runs vertically and down there
so where was the body electrical in uh
electrical
um i was in navigation so i was no
worried
i was waiting to i was uh i had my hand
on the [ __ ] scanning thing waiting
for somebody to well we don't know when
the kill happened though
so i don't know i'm also working towards
scanning thing right now with k-town
uh yeah yeah alana i passed you and
someone else
going from navigation down south i
assume two electrical which is where you
can
fight me
no i went from cafeteria across to
reactor
i've not gone down yeah electrical you
wouldn't know
you were now uh oh now you're originally
in oh sure
that's where i first was who left admin
because i think admin john rising and i
were there and then
was it cricket and who else left it to
go to react and when it went i did not
see who else left because i was doing
the download thing and it covered my
screen a lot
won't me hmm
don't i [ __ ] cause what's your heart
rate like right now
very calm having a great time not
killing anybody
doing tasks you know how it'd be i'm
skipping i don't know
why
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna vote me out even
though i ain't done [ __ ] and the pro it
is a problem that i have with this game
how did you get there so fast what is he
broken
um i
cool great great
that was slow
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh i have short-term
memory issues sometimes because of
illnesses um that can definitely cause
me issues with this game where i will
see something and then a second [ __ ]
later be like i'm sorry what
i don't remember where i was at all and
then it's pretty sus it's just
i don't know what what i'm supposed to
[ __ ] do about it
i actually think john's alright diction
maybe sus
see i was like primed for murder there
you know now this is covering my whole
[ __ ] screen
you know i really could have been
murdered okay okay okay okay
[ __ ]
why am i why am i fighting all these
goddamn bodies this is what happened to
me last time
it was an upper reactor or lower reactor
by the the hand print thing and uh
i saw andy earlier we had we both did
the uh the reactor handprint thing
the first time so i was going to do it
again and there he was dead i don't
remember seeing anyone
so you were nervous where's everybody
else
i'm an electrical i have three tasks
literally every single one of those back
toss and electrical i just did
and i saw i believe john in there i did
see diction in there and diction just
left and i was like he could have
murdered me then if he wanted but he
didn't yeah we were hella alone for a
while
yeah i was yeah i was i was creeping on
them from the doorway making sure
they're all
playing nice i was walking through calf
with the
krykin at the very end toward reactor
when it went off how do we not have
anyone who's even saw us we gotta vote
someone out
all right i just walked in why not dude
i was talking no i gotta go i got
there's another body and i know where
that other body was
where was it why would you know where
the body is
because i was on a security camera just
say
because you said you're coming across
the cafeteria where the other body was
on the other side
also cranking i saw you go through a
vent but we could have come up
hold up did you just say you still crack
and go through event i did not go
through an event
at the very beginning i feel like you
should have brought that up earlier john
now i'm so severe
i don't know what to do
okay oh my goodness bye guys
i really guessed i don't [ __ ] know
why would you not mention the vent
immediately the [ __ ] hell
okay i'm [ __ ] in it like the
imposters out here i'm gonna [ __ ] die
i don't
young [ __ ] swear to god
nine zero six five three enter
yeah somebody gonna go do that other one
or are we gonna [ __ ] are we gonna is
this there we go you did it you did it
i'm proud of you don't kill me don't
kill me don't kill me don't kill me
kraken maybe i can trust crikey
cracking cracking amber's cracking
embers okay
okay uh oh
i was gonna say i wanted to go back to
like check to see if like if kraken's
dead now
it brews but
i'm hitting the button because i'm
scared
that someone's gonna die so i passed
lana
and she's gonna be doing her task
everything's fine uh bruce ran past
me and didn't kill me and i was afraid
so i walked
around him but i got i got locked and i
got locked in admin behind you that's
what happened
yeah i got locked out of the uh what are
you in the top right
yeah yeah i did top oxygen and then i
was running to
uh reactor i can actually vouch for
carry there because i did seem a topic i
don't know who did
oxygen
then where was your diction i was over
in weapons
cool what are you doing over there what
were you doing there i had something in
oxygen i think and then i had i was
going back to do the uh the
little lab thing with the bottles or
whatever the vials
i don't know if i've ever had a round
where i've been so clueless about who's
sauced the whole time
i know this is i don't like this okay
i've i've seen a lot i've seen kraken
i really addiction i i think you're okay
in that i think you've had prime
opportunity to kill me several times but
i said that about andy lost around and
he was [ __ ] motorist
but i think that you've had chances to
kill me a bunch and didn't
yeah why would i do that if i we don't
have one
i don't know what the tasks are at but
we don't have to vote here yeah we don't
have it's pretty close
okay i mean it was definitely john i
think i have two left
i guess i'm going to because it doesn't
sound like we know and i don't want to
vote for dick yeah
i don't actually know okay all right
we'll skip i appreciate that
[ __ ] nice checking in glad you guys are
all still alive
yeah yeah it's good to know you guys
miss you be safe out there yeah
i missed you off real quick shut up andy
or your masks
all right i'm [ __ ] nervous i've got
three tasks left [ __ ]
what have you done
you you you both really got [ __ ]
tossed out here huh really
both of you bruce bruce
i'm just trying to get my [ __ ] done man
oh well this is pretty tidy
okay
[ __ ]
bruce i should i did wanna i did want to
but i
you know i just i was like what i don't
have anything to do
[Laughter]
oh i didn't jump on a sword let me talk
right here okay
[Laughter]
i said both you and bruce came over from
where the other dead body was so i was
suss about both of you
you at one point went into the
electrical and then i came back and you
were gone
you must have just peeked in there
because you went in there so fast
you seemed like you vented out i did not
see that one
i peeked i said that i peeked from the
door i was creeping
but i did not jump in a sword note if i
ever come with
a a labra story like that again i am not
the killer
i am not that creative from our
perspective like
bringing up oh someone vented at the end
of a meeting
seemed like a really you'd do that you'd
call a meeting to say that
no what i was trying to do was i was
trying to get everybody to talk about
where they were
without telling you where the other body
was
okay yeah i see i got the logic i was
about to say where i was which would
probably have [ __ ] me
but then you brought that up and it
totally took it away from me and i'm
very glad that you did that john
yeah so if somebody events just maybe
say that first is all i'm saying
john let me just come out what might as
well happen is like i know who the
killer is and then the whole room goes
dark and it comes back and there's a
knife in your chest
that's what it was but he also got the
wrong killer he said
oh boy that was chaotic i was so glad
that i was alone with people so many
times so people didn't suspect me
because i kept finding bodies and it was
right
yeah no i i've been alone with you a
bunch of times it was alright it was i
you didn't but we should have grouped
together again the end probably also
my chapter is a good point if bruce was
sussed purely because he was not
attacking me that entire round he was
not
breaking oh no i don't really
i don't want to go after kraken or alana
because they're both like generally you
guys are both pretty good at the game
except for craic and sherlocking at the
beginning so
that's a good that's a good step for me
sherlocking and getting the imposter
okay
no not that no no no when you voted me
off the first round and i wasn't getting
the pot
it was second round yeah
nobody's perfect it's probably perfect
guys
all right uh yeah let's go
and to everybody else who was dead fredo
and uh rising were trying to talk to me
i didn't know we were doing that i was
like [ __ ] up
yeah when you're dead you can talk the
ghosts may speak
thank god what if i could play this
whole time without getting imposter that
would be [ __ ] beautiful
um okay let's go medpay
toss on i don't know because maybe i
could like get somebody to like scan oh
it's not the scanner
that's a bummer right
okay now i have to wait 56 [ __ ]
seconds
she okay we need to go to electrical
this is how i die
isn't it this is where this is where it
gets me
my death impending i've been alive for
too many rounds
i don't like it nobody else is in here
you [ __ ] [ __ ] really
all right uh i just
fixed electrical the uh light expanded
to move and
found kraken dead on the floor in
electrical roots went after him you son
of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i i will say that it it looked a little
suspicious
but it also makes perfect sense that you
couldn't see the body because i just
walked in yeah walked in everything was
closed on me i walked into the box i
fixed electrical so it expanded out
i wouldn't have fixed it if i were bad
and then walked over and saw our body
i'm sorry yes on alfredo because it was
dark and i was scared
and i saw like a flash and by the time
the lights came on he was like
just far away enough where he probably
was gonna kill me
probably fredo yeah it's that's pretty
sus dude what's your rebuttal
or he was on a kill cooldown when he was
running to the right side with all of us
well i was like in storage
and then i was like going
away from electrical because i just
thought people would be there and i
didn't want to die right right where the
body was
and i was coming from an admin when
there was nobody okay
all right
[Applause]
so nobody saw anybody leaving
oh no i never went to electrical i was
in storage and then i got
scared of going in dave had ample time
to kill me in admin and didn't
hmm that's all i'm going to say well
there's a kill cooldown at the beginning
also there he is you're right
john i feel like you're being quiet i'm
just listening to this little discord is
happening and eating my uh
visits john's gonna go well you know
what guys i saw somebody
[Music]
what kind of cheese it's the toasted
ones oh
that's pretty [ __ ] sus bro that's
pretty suspicious incredible
wait did all honestly the extra posted
ones are sus yeah that sucks as [ __ ] bro
all right i'm voting you next round no
matter what wow that's sauce too that's
also
sauce okay bye
uh all right can i go like finish my med
base situation or what
i can beautiful
that's a sat i just hit that in it that
there beautiful
love it love to see it okay i do need to
go back to
the killing pen that is electrical
can i go somewhere else first because
electrical let's go storage let's go
storage it's a through way you know
it's very open people don't like
committing murder i'm just going to pop
my head in an admin
see okay everyone's alright in here andy
andy andy andy
andy andy
bruce andy bruce oh what is this oh
that's the other one i have to do okay
okay okay first first first please first
don't do this to me first i'm just doing
my task
okay you weird candy cane manny chasing
me bro you chasing me right now bro
i shouldn't have walked into electrical
first
first first
all right i do have somebody tossing
that
and everyone's in there right so if i
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] they all left i'm just i'm
just trying to do my toss and electrical
while not being murdered by bursts
[ __ ] off first maybe he's also just
doing toss i don't know
what was happening in there i got real
scared of you bruce i was like i'm
trying not to die but i have to do it
oh
uh the body was in storage um
oh damn on the bottom uh
right door like just going towards
lights
okay so dave why was it me
i'm sorry man i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know that first electrical
was bruce and i i was scared bruce fixed
the lights and then the lights came back
up two other people walked in and then
like walked out and walked in
which means we have a lot of people andy
and fredo
i was trying to walk back in and see if
i was going to see a dead body and
i did that once too so i feel like that
group of people was at least accounted
for in electrical
and then unlocked the doors before sorry
alana go on
no go ahead okay i was in electrical
uh a little bit before the lights went
and someone locked the doors
on both ends so i don't know how door
locking actually works
but is it it would it just be like that
corridor that's locked
and then for electrical it's just the
electrical door would get locked
there's only one way out of electrical
right convenient that you know that john
the corridor the corridor
inside of there like four words bruce
shut up
when i walked left to go to electrical i
left alana in storage and i don't know
who else was in storage alana was doing
the task on the top that
should the same task i did where you um
actually i don't
even know the [ __ ] task is the one
right near the doorway though near the
hallway of admin
i say that i'm just kidding i'm skipping
but i say keep an eye on freedom
i actually think fredo's clear i i
actually fully think fredo is clean
i don't know alfredo
that's why i think he's all right coming
from my neck this is wild
no i said i trust you fam no i didn't i
didn't accuse you john
john rising is too quiet he's gonna kill
you
i did make myself suss multiple times
there though let that be let that be
uh addressed accidentally by being so
suspicious of everyone else
but hey i'm not a murderer i'm not
killing anyone
let's go [ __ ] navigation
do some [ __ ] navigating what are you
doing up there john is this how i die
you're gonna [ __ ] come off to me you
stupid [ __ ]
it's how i talk to my friends don't
worry about it okay
i'm worried john is gonna kill me
zero eight two one nine enter
beautiful first
first first first wipers
all right okay
i knew it wasn't [ __ ] fredo
okay who is it who
okay so the body is outside of
electrical
who saw anybody running near storage
jurisdiction and i were all just top
right
john was also but he could have left by
that point but
also keep in mind that people can vent
yeah that's yeah
okay no but okay no but i i will say
this but
it isn't in electrical like i don't
think it's
i don't think it's anywhere where the
killer could have gotten to the vent
that quickly
i guess we don't know how far upon her
all i can say is that bruce is currently
definitely accounted for
because i was scared because he seemed
like he was chasing andy was with i
think alana
near the start uh when i
yeah they were the last two people i saw
i went to the top
left i did the immediate task in the
cafeteria and then alana came to do the
same thing and my
the thought went through my head like
elana's been doing all the [ __ ] same
tasks that i've got
we have to build someone up we have to i
saw alana at the start pass by as i was
doing the download and then i went
down and did the oxygen uh
code wow i don't think that's true john
because i think bruce and i just did the
oxygen code
nobody had done that one that one didn't
go so they reported the body before
when i was i was running to admin to do
the other one we gotta vote
we gotta vote somebody off so who is it
i think
i i i'm sauce of john but i'm also a
little bit suspicious
did that you know what i'm voting alana
i said i was going to vote lana for the
toaster thing let's just roll with it
i don't know why not what is diction
i was in the cafeteria going to do the
second oxygen
in admin i i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure either but i
think we need to vote someone else did
my taxes
i voted for john only because bruce is
going after him but i could be bruce
just doing a really good play i don't
know
that's true he could be galaxy brain
it's true but also i'm
a lot of sus watch out for a lot of not
at all
like not even a little bit i thought
[ __ ]
i may have just been galaxy brained by
bruce is the problem
i haven't even accounted for dave he's
[ __ ] it's us too right
all right i gotta go up into electrical
this is where i [ __ ] die
i hate this stupid room
the thing that gets me with what john
did there
is if you immediately try to out someone
because they've outed you i think that's
impossible
[ __ ] like you don't want to get rid of
someone unless you have an actual
suspicion on them which she said
something about a toaster
i think i don't know what i did oh well
that's locked
and i done dave
was [ __ ] dave
it's hurt so much more when a british
person lies to you
you know because you think their their
accent's
all the [ __ ] betrayal you should make
it sound like they're nice
oh
oh no okay yeah oh okay
okay hold on hold on it's got to be okay
dave is definitely one of them
i mean me you and bruce we're just we're
all done with our testimonies
just hanging out yes i'm done with me
and bruce and dave have all been done
with our testimony on the cafeteria and
dave and alana were the only ones not
seen david's gotta be one of them
i i i agree with andy right
dave is the only one that was
unaccounted for for the last one dave i
agree with andy
i trusted you because you were british
how long was the round it was a bad idea
strong enough for you
i could be getting huge big brains right
now but i agree with andy
no i do i have no tasks i have no more
tasks
i don't either i'm done that's why i was
circling that table you'd love to see it
i hope we just won
oh no come on come on oh no come on come
on come on please be you dave please be
dave
well no so the reason i got i got mad
such of you john is i'm very sass of
anyone who ever
if they get accused goes well then it's
you because generally if you're a crew
mate you don't want someone to die just
because they've accused you right
that's right that made me like no that's
impossible
for me it was either alana or john and i
was like [ __ ] like alana was i was with
the entire time or she could have been
venting she's really good i was like
[ __ ] i don't know
oh thank you but it was not me you
didn't kill anyone
we could i'm taking a 30 minute break
because i have to take my kids to their
mom's house i'll be back
if there's still room for me if not no
worries okay all right
love you man have a good one i'll be
back no worries
can we talk about that around real quick
because first of all i've never seen you
as an imposter and
i the look of my face was that of shock
and betrayal me too
i was like not dave
but i i did but then you called the
meeting and they're like
it's him and your defense was uh
when they were all in that i was like
cool they're all in here i'm gonna have
time to like you know hang out but then
they started moving and i was like
if they move and find the body i mean i
don't know if i'm the only one who left
and i it was a gamble on if anyone else
had not been done with tasks
it was like a 50 50. yeah there was so
many tests
someone had to so if i called the
meeting it's less sus if i'm
checking if someone's died or not you
know yeah
totally that makes sense that was uh
that was a very good self-report you
need to jump in and like establish a
defense right away and like why you
called a meeting
you you called it you're like it's him
and you're like if john would have
killed one more person and this is not
blaming him at all it's because we can't
communicate but
there was a point where if he killed one
more we'd have been very easily like
it'd be easy to just
like over vote the right cast
it's tough when everyone's together and
it's like you have to
you split them up somehow oh yeah for
sure and it was very stressful i know my
gosh
you did great it's been great really
stressful yeah that was actually really
good getting us down to four
was really cool yeah i did not suspect
you until i literally saw you vent as a
ghost
so you know you did you did well uh uh
we got
oh farley's in there's farley uh partly
the codes and discords paul hey farley
okay uh you guys i thought i don't know
has anybody not met farley before
oh i know i haven't hey
hey hey buddy hi carrie
my name's carrie nice to meet you hello
excellent what all right yeah farley is
harley is always the imposter pretty
much oh god
i am very rarely the imposter and then
having it two times in a row almost give
me my heart
yeah that was really good i'm happy to
just do my task from now on
i just want to be a good little boy
that's all i want
[Laughter]
um who said somebody said they were
leaving for a second who was that
crazy right john rising
oh no he's leaving for a long time i
think cricket might have said he was
gonna go get a drink
oh okay yeah maybe i think so maybe
yeah this game makes me so nervous and i
always drink a lot of water and i i just
i just gotta pee all the time like i'm
always nervous and [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's a pretty sauce andy
who urinates i just wait until i die and
then i i run as quickly as i can
yeah i think i i think andy's a killer
guys i just pissed my pants
like if i was to kill her when i pissed
myself in front of you all
i don't think so all over the place
kind of gross man we could get a 10th
person in
uh yeah um maybe maybe rahul
no this is all of my friends accounted
for actually did you guys know you're my
best friends
um and then i don't have any others yes
uh can't wait to meet you i'm sure we'll
have a great time
uh yeah if anybody i'll believe that for
a second yeah except for you andy
if anybody has an extra uh feel free to
get him in here but uh
um that i do i think bree is on the way
oh that's kind of waiting for bree but
but yeah i know what's going on
she put her face on on twitter i can see
it right now okay
all right so she's got to be close guys
this isn't my camera i'm putting a
picture of my world of warcraft
character on there my chat's bullying me
well that's pretty [ __ ] nutty dude
that's some real node [ __ ] it's new
okay wow i love electrical it's my
favorite
andy come on now andy andy come on
andy oh i gotta hold it
what are y'all doing i'm hanging out
zero one done how did i do that
did andy just leave is that what just
happened then did he just [ __ ] bounce
while i was doing that code
why has he done that
if i watch yourself for a screen you
[ __ ] watch yourselves
yup i didn't even press that on purpose
there's a diamond in here
she those are like girls best
friends i don't know why i'm doing so
much uh
hey bud um valley girl today but
sometimes it happens
all right okay let's go just connecting
wires not a problem
to do some [ __ ] on admin get my [ __ ]
tasks done out here fam
i'm so bad at this okay just a medium
speed
oh
oh baby boy oh boy wow
okay barley what the [ __ ] is discord so
you're right it's not falling uh
well i've really been trying to vote for
farley
all i'm really saying is i think andy
had opportunity to kill me a few times
and didn't
but right now
[Music]
i'm really really bad with the room what
is med bay again
uh directly left of cafeteria and then
down
where the scans are okay yeah yeah yeah
okay the body scanner
i was yeah i was just locked in a room
with k-town and i think
andy maybe you came in when the door's
unlocked i'm not sure but k-town was
there doing
well what were you doing okay time what
was your task i was doing the
the gas refill yeah i saw that i saw
that i
i feel like we could have easily killed
each other because the doors were locked
and i think
and then i went over to electrical i did
my thing up there uh dave ran in and
then andy ran in
as i was leaving so we are all in that
electrical area i trust carrie because i
saw him do the
o2 in admin uh thank you
i'm a little suss on andy yeah so i did
the other o2 and i will say andy was
there before i got there but i finished
it andy did you just
bail halfway through doing a code or
what
no it's not the code it's when you
release the [ __ ] thing on the top
right oh
i walked by i had to put the code in for
the o2
and you were on it
and then you just left so what's
happened here
we don't have to vote but are you
talking about the reactor thing i'm the
one who typed in the reaction i skipped
i skipped because i don't know
i skipped i'm a little um now i'm
confused
did alfredo stay silent that whole time
for [ __ ] sake and also alfredo said is
it a self report even though he reported
[Laughter]
i don't know what's happening
okay admin i'm gonna go do that
i'm taking a risk on you bruce taking a
chance on you
beautiful uh
oh okay i can do this because i'm right
[ __ ] here see it is a code right
did i am i crazy did i not see andy on
that [ __ ] code and then
leave no i'm not sure
we are getting our tasks done though hey
frito
what's what you've been up to lately bro
you hanging out you just
having a good time oh
they got dave how did fredo's
self-report again
all right it's almost definitely andy
i'm gonna let this one
uh explain himself real quick wait what
happened
i just saw dave and andy run out of
electrical and go north
hold on but uh andy you want to explain
yourself mandy explain what
i mean you know you know what you did
andy
what'd you do andy what what are you
doing right now freda from cash
i'm coming in the admin the body falls
over i see you panic bro and then you
run into admin that report
i didn't run into admin what are you
talking about oh
did you get the color right yeah no i
did
spit sauce fam
and i was just like bro carrie you were
[ __ ] on the money with this one
that's pretty fragrant didn't kill me
fredo had a chance to kill me and oxen
and didn't
even though he's fine twice was guarding
you
he's okay i don't know what play fredo
is doing right now i really don't
okay the only thing i will say in any
defense is that he and dave did run
out of electrical together so
he could have theoretically killed him
soon early in the round did they do that
though
uh it was about like 10 seconds before
the body was found
okay so it was actually pretty late
i dude i do not know what play fredo was
trying to do right now like i have no
idea where did you find the body because
i saw you in oxygen and then and then
what happened yeah then i
i went up to weapons and then i went
from calf to admin
i paused fredo and calf exactly and the
body was
right there either andy [ __ ] up or
fredo's going big brain
i saw it fall over andy passed me and
then ran
into admin i did not even run into admin
what are you talking about
that's crazy i'm going in he definitely
went north towards admin
wait what what are we doing i voted andy
because i don't freda was so confident
with the report
are you kidding me it could be fredo it
could be fredo i thought god
okay okay guilt trip 2020 over here
nitro i'm worried about
he's just such a wild card man you never
know what freda's gonna do
what's he gonna do i don't [ __ ] know
hey bro hey y'all i'm just here doing
this task real quick
before we have to run to the other one
all right
i feel like we maybe got some ghosts up
in here not doing their [ __ ] tasks is
what's happening
if i'm being perfectly honest oh my god
are we gonna time out
[ __ ] [ __ ]
this is so far away
holy [ __ ] oh my god they did it okay
thank god okay
oh jesus all right all right all right
all right
i would really like to not die in
electrical
right now if one of your [ __ ]
walks in here
now i'm in the closet now i'm in the
closet too
hey fredo
did he just vent in here did
i don't know how afraid i showed up
there um because i wasn't paying enough
attention did he just [ __ ]
did he just not sure what just happened
uh so
that was a bit weird um but now i'm
scared
i'm not sure what happened
i don't
so bruce would you like to explain
yourself oh
do you mean because fredo and i just did
reactor no i mean because i was on cams
when you killed andy or what are you
killed uh
harley wow wait what
you just called farley farley was killed
was it first or second round
you killed someone
you killed someone okay that's enough
for me i was a bit self-righteous but uh
you
you bruce you got caught killing someone
yeah yeah you've been friendly
a couple of times there wait a minute so
fredo and i just did reactor together
yeah you you knew you got caught on the
cam so you started an emergency so i
couldn't call this meeting
you sabotaged the reactor i didn't even
know you could have the person at the
time
you could kill fredo i didn't even know
you could do that
i don't even know i like i literally had
no idea that you could but you're just
trying to pretend that you didn't get
caught murdering someone is that what's
happening here
like what's the justification
yeah cause i don't even know it was one
of the one of the four cameras i don't
know it was a hallway somewhere
i thought i thought it was weird i got
on cams as soon as i got out of camps i
watched
someone walked away from reactor when it
went off
i thought that was weird but i mean if
you went and waited for the button that
line
that lines up yeah no totally i mean it
does but
nope i'm positive this is burst
i'm afraid you know i've done it i'm
quite sure you're right
based on reactions that i've seen before
we gotta be right or i'm gonna be mad
embarrassed but i'm like quite positive
i think i think we're good i think we're
good
ggs bros that's a [ __ ] gigi's does
that mean we did it what does that mean
andy
oh [ __ ] you you want to talk about how
you
saved me from electric bro literally
i literally got on cams and two seconds
later you killed him like they just got
lucky
no i wasn't suss of you at all bruce but
the reaction that was a bit like
wait what yeah because he didn't know
yeah he was chasing me and i was running
for
kill dave i'm gonna [ __ ] vent and the
kilting pop like the colored pops up but
i still had two seconds didn't notice it
went for the kill nothing happened i was
like oh what the [ __ ] and i just
panicked and i hit vent on accident and
yourself as [ __ ]
and i bent it back in and chased dave
for like two miles
well historically when he must
my brain was focused on was the orange
which is your color and the fact that
you were still alive after the animation
happened
yeah yeah i mean he wasn't wrong he was
just i was i was
i'm just really bad with names yeah you
just want right the right way but you
weren't wrong
and it's like i saw bruce kill and then
i'm like yes and he like
quotes two wrong people i'm like
totally wrong memorable dude
[Laughter]
very terrible killing i'm sorry oh yeah
you [ __ ]
okay another round we're making it
through we're not an imposter yet you
[ __ ] love to see it let's go to
storage shall we let's go down here into
storage
and not get my neck stamped that's all
i'm trying to do just having a good day
not dying not killing anyone making it
through
that's um that's what we want to [ __ ]
see so
well i probably should go do that huh
this is where we die i hate electrical
okay cool bye everyone bye and get the
[ __ ] out of here
oh they all got locked in somebody might
die in there
you know could happen
all right cool
i do have another thing over here what
are you doing dave obama what are you
doing
huh you're just hanging out being
british yeah yeah
you know being ex-presidential in that
you're just looking at
wi-fi symbols hey bud you gonna [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off dave so what i'm saying you
want to get the [ __ ] away from me don't
chase me around the [ __ ] table
right okay okay everybody
that's how i talk to dogs they get very
excited
okay
i'm just trying to get my tasks done can
you stop like you know being dramatic
and sabotaging and [ __ ] all right uh do
i have to go to
wow this is far away actually
they both got it okay cool cool
everybody's like suspiciously alive
from what i can tell what if i just look
at
no i can't do it in there security's
over the other side that's right that's
right that's right that's right
oh cool great it happened again
i do have to go to electrical my least
favorite place to go
but i do have to [ __ ] go back there
who is dave obama i just caught someone
in chat ask that um it's funny
i don't know
that took a while i made it for a round
yay
i found pigtan's body over by navigation
and i did not i do not believe i
remember
passing anyone in the hallway or
anything it was a really long round
before
no eyes on andy did anyone last seen
leslie andy i had never seen it yeah i
don't think i've really seen any at all
i've seen dave and that's pretty much it
yep i thought dave i saw lana i said oh
yeah
yeah i briefly saw i can stop first at
these
i saw yellow coming up to cap at the end
too
yeah i think went mad bae bruce early i
was with fredo for a little bit
and i saw i think a lot on your storage
or something
asking by yeah i just went through
storage to go do my tuscan electrical
yeah i trust dave i trust alana
uh i kind of trust diction
means a lot man you know
did anybody see addiction in all the
entire round yeah i mean me and you and
dave were
at admin remember when the doors closed
we're just killing that yeah yeah
okay all right okay well yeah have fun
don't die
all right i feel like i guess maybe the
rules that i played most recently were a
lot more intense than this like these
rounds are like long and chill
i'm just like i'm gonna cool time oh
anyway
the story i was telling about dave sorry
um yeah i don't know
uh i've just streamed with the guy a
bunch like him a lot
but i don't know who he is dave dave
dave dave
dave dave
i swear to [ __ ] god dude that was
that was [ __ ] weird dave
don't [ __ ] me dave i see you
staring at me right here okay okay okay
okay
okay what's the situation dave
what's what's the plan i do have to go
to admin
maybe he was trying to kill me there but
didn't because folly walked in or some
[ __ ]
hmm
[Music]
that's pretty [ __ ] sus bro okay just
walk past me there that's nice
um oh okay i can do o2 i'm right here
i'm right here
six eight nine one three
done beautiful
uh i want to go to security
great yep great
looking at the cameras when he was
killed
yeah oh alana's dead now too oh my god
it's like dude that's like that scene in
harry potter with the guy that uh oh is
it was hermione with the the mirror and
she was looking at the basilisk and it
froze her
you know i can why are you all peeing
hey
[Music]
we want kermit back
wait wait dave where'd you find the body
uh in cams
security i was in cantons when i think
the lights were out so the lights went
out i went over to cams
just to sit on it see if i could see
anybody and then once lights came back
up i left
[Music]
that we were just dealing with so the
only person i can actually vouch for is
dave because dave
i feel like he would maybe he maybe he
would have killed then gone
reported but i watched dave walk over
where he
i think okay folly just said he was an
admin which was the last place i saw
alana when i was
a man towards uh security yeah and folly
was to the south of me and alana was
alone doing that communications one that
covers up your whole screen for a couple
seconds
okay so dave what are you saying we have
thirty seconds
because they both just jumped on it
don't help me
holy [ __ ]
yeah these guys are a mess right i am
[ __ ] idiots i mean they're alive but
they're dumb yeah i mean
dave was absolutely right about folly
and why did he drop it
probably [ __ ] killed me and then he
was just like
anyway it's fredo no you were right
the second i heard that i was like yes
thank you yeah
oh bruce is
holy [ __ ]
you were like folly followed alana he
absolutely did and killed me
and then you dropped it
out of all people like i can't i have to
like you know yeah
it was those two and i literally said
whoever you pick i will vote
i'm with you definitely he said i picked
fredo and we both voted fredo and he's
like man never mind
and then just through the game
don't ever tie that vote never tie that
vote vote out
because otherwise that was [ __ ]
chaotic man i'm just throwing the game
out
like a big brain play they voted
immediately it's them
yeah what the [ __ ] was that uh it's like
we trust you dave
we then
[Laughter]
yeah good impulse to play there dave uh
you did a great job you really helped
really help the team good stuff
could not have gone worse i'm sorry oh
brie is here hi
i've been trying to do the last couple
and i somehow miss you by a second so
i'm so glad
i'm finally here you're right oh yeah
let's go let's go let's go
okay cafeteria
i'm doing my tasks getting my job done
this game is real quiet you know i got
to fill the silence with something for
you guys
you guys at home watching me not be
impostor which i'm very happy about
keep it up love it love to see it
go to across the board this is my ideal
way to play this game
really um
all right let me finish my task and then
do [ __ ] okay yeah all right
follow you better do that are we gonna
watch folly
get it okay okay
oh well then what happened okay
but freda that was an emergency meeting
not a report right
i don't know i don't know on the meeting
cricket's never gonna play this [ __ ]
ever
i don't know how we again about like
meta gaming and stuff but i saw
bree and nav at the download and it
takes eight seconds she was there for a
solid 12. it was really weird
so did you call this meeting to judge me
is that
i'm just wondering okay okay no no it's
coming
it's hard and fast also uh just so you
know fredo
right before he muted said oh hell yeah
impost and then
yeah but he does it every round too i
don't know if we're gonna do
uh meta gaming but uh you said you were
the imposter
[Laughter]
oh hell yeah imposter time is that why
you're trying to put cess on me that way
no one says of you because i can explain
why i took so long
yeah go okay i had the game muted when i
had it
up and it was waiting to join because it
was just like oh no like space music and
then i realized i started playing the
game and it was still muted and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm not able to hear anything so i
kind of freaked out a little bit also
you were just like staring at me in the
hallway and i was like
do i move i don't know it's going to
kill me i don't know and then bruce came
up and i was like okay
unless they're both the killer i think
i'm okay
with the thing on your screen he was
watching me download and then judged me
for taking too long after staring at me
like i'm sorry i was like morgan space i
can't believe she didn't sign up for
fiber it's crazy
i was just like whoa and then brie was
like [ __ ] you freddie i was like god
damn
damn it must be pretty bad when you tell
everyone you're the imposter like you
gotta come up with some sort
of likes to throw sauce on himself yeah
he does see that every single
round like right is this a self report
you guys
never it might have been it might have
been like when i killed kraken and
caught
storage let's go shall we [ __ ] press
the wrong button on my keyboard because
i moved
put my knee in the way bloody yo all
right
okay you [ __ ] sabotage [ __ ]
sabotaging and [ __ ] oh that's too many
of you
somebody in that squad is about to
[ __ ] die
that's all i'm saying is it bria
doesn't seem like it's bria you [ __ ]
suspect are you doing some
[ __ ] you being sneaky i'm gonna go to
shields
i'm gonna go to shields i'm not gonna
die fredo you're not gonna [ __ ] kill
me bro neither are you
but if folly really not oh they're
together
[Music]
hey what up
in the afterlife yeah it's pretty chill
out here
i thought that i was safe because two
people walked into a room but it's
actually that they're killing together
as a team
they are double killing yeah it's smart
generally pretty pretty risky
yeah we got killed like right next to
each other just numbers
yeah no i know because i was like oh
lana saw it
i too am dead hmm
it's a good tactic i always hover over
the report button just in case but when
you're in like a task it's really hard
to hold that's a good
that's a good call actually electrical
yeah uh i went to electrical first thing
which i've now learned is a mistake
yeah electrical is where you go to
[ __ ] die up
because i was afraid of going to where
the thing was
and i knew someone would have killed
them there so i just called a meeting
and saved us all the trouble
the thing was what thank you what thing
well okay so two people have made
yourself sauce accidentally
yes rest in peace we love playing really
but um i saw alana
going down to the bottom right before
she died and i also saw
bria and i just caught a glimpse of
fredo but he was in the top left
so i don't think he killed them
and more more importantly if they both
died
at the bottom uh right where i saw them
the emergency was all on the left-hand
side of the ship so whoever did it
killed them there called the emergency
so that only people
who report c and we we we have to all go
there
so if anyone saw someone going down that
way
or perhaps even venting i would assume
they would be the killers okay okay
um andy and i don't know interesting
i don't know a whole lot but i do want
to say that
and i don't want to blame carrie for
anything because i do the same thing all
the time
i do the same [ __ ] all the time where
i am in a room and then leave and
realize i still had another task in that
room
but carrie was kind of in electrical and
then left kind of going towards storage
and then
went back to electrical and i
i thought that was a little bit sus see
i wasn't gonna say anything about
you but i did see you addiction running
away from oxygen
earlier because because everybody who
plays with me knows that i never like
if i'm close i just uh somebody will
also take care of that [ __ ]
something if
you don't have any first yeah yeah
i gotta have a meeting i guess
that backfired uh quite badly
i mean it's sound logic
okay
you think that how they uh how they
expected
yeah dave's running the lobby too much
now this is this is bad for dave
dave's running the lobby oh you mean you
think that he's gonna he does
accidentally make himself
target he does because anybody who talks
a
lot
generally like if you're trying to run
the lobby usually you're not
a crewmate you don't just agree i
i mean yeah i mean i talk a lot if i've
seen anything worth discussing
all right but what i'm saying she's not
an imposter than what she is
but what i'm saying is every lobby so
like every single time because dave
doesn't see something every single round
so true yeah i mean he did seem
suspended
i finished all my tasks yeah
i think he went good i mean he uh well
nobody voted no
addiction defended folly defended
they're still just hanging out together
well yeah they're gonna do double kills
here
[Music]
she does that i thought it was her okay
okay oh um [ __ ] why did you think it was
her
because she's just been kind of i don't
know she's just you know
fredo was throwing like or who was
throwing suspicion at her there was
three people in electrical in the
wilderness right now
that he was imposter before we started
playing
i'm gonna just pick that up huh who saw
anybody going near electrical
i was with someone in communications
security
and they went down and then i
i went a bit after them and that's when
i found bria's body because
okay so that was where was the body
electrical
okay there were three people in
electrical and then one person vented to
security
was that before after the lights just
right the [ __ ] now
like after the lights oh i ran i was
running to security to go try to see
who maybe left security but uh the body
was reported immediately
i passed her in columns and i i did a
whole check on the right side to see if
there's any bodies there
and then i ended my route going
they're wasting so much time oh my gosh
what is it uh weapons over to calf
and then like these two just honestly i
don't
i i was kind of such afraid of but i saw
afraid of leaving medbay
right as somebody who had just vented to
security so i don't think it's fredo
they're just silent killers i did see
i saw andy watching the security thing
you saw somebody event
though no i saw no no no i i'm looking
at the admin
window oh my gosh where it shows you
people in rooms
and there's three people in electric and
then somebody vent and so there's three
bodies in electric
one disappears one pops up in security
gotcha
okay dixon and folly what do you guys
think especially diction who's
not said a word i didn't see anything
you're on it dave if you're honest
yes andy yes okay you're learning andy
oh we're proud of you andy i feel like
every all these people are screaming at
us right now
these guys gotta make a decision [ __ ]
hell man they have to go to fix they
have to vote at six or that's it
yeah i think that's what they want to do
where are they now they're gonna get
double killed
oh man that yeah that one was tough to
watch
that one was tough dave is on it but i
know
well andy said andy literally said folly
addiction at the end though
but but they didn't didn't action it you
know
okay okay all right folly what's the
plan here oh oh
oh no yeah oh this is how it goes down
right
okay maybe andy will break away
they might be okay there's enough of
them there's enough of them report nope
oh
so now it's always farley guys so just
keep that in mind
two in a row for parley i [ __ ] knew
it god damn it [ __ ] yeah you said it
right in that last round andy you're
like but you guys didn't do anything
about it but you like dictionary and
following
us a hell of a favor by constantly
calling meetings like that and just kind
of making himself a little bit
[ __ ] up dave was right
everything he said was right everyone
yeah
yeah it's just like a good one someone
needs to
make an action on when i do stuff stupid
yeah it's true it's true
all right let's [ __ ] go
i'm just like gonna go to like admin
hey kraken hey craig hey craig hey hey
am i gonna die in here this is like one
of the dumbest things i've ever done
like none of what i just did was smart
not even really sure why i did it you
know that was not
like self-preservation just [ __ ] out
the window on that one man damn
all right guess we'll hang out up up
hello god damn folly's dead body
up in the top of the cafeteria well
that's good
the toughest right it's him it does
eliminate him that's true
we don't have to worry about farley we
don't worry about it um yeah i walk from
admin
when i were both in admin and then it
was just i just walked up as just as the
doors closed and yeah
i can clear well i can't clear alana
because she found it but i clear bruce
because i
followed him from admin down to
electrical fix the lights and then back
so he can't have done it well cricket
was following me the entire time of
being super cess
but he didn't kill me so there's that
hmm
uh okay i mean it was weird you were
you're being weird you weren't doing any
tasks that's right i
literally was i did all the tests yeah
i'm pretty sure that chris
did the admin test right now i didn't do
any tasks
then why were you just standing in admit
alone why didn't you do any tasks
because i was trying not to get to not
get killed by criken over and over and
over
hmm i'll skip did anybody else see
anybody up
north anybody else top right
it was an electrical when their body was
called they were like it was me yeah
that was it was afraid top half
electrical yeah yeah
well okay that was quite franken and
bruce i'm gonna be
real mad i'm really confused i was
trying to clear bruce and now he's
throwing suss on me and i'm not
no i i genuinely think you guys are okay
i think you guys are okay
it's super it's super weird like you can
accidentally everybody stop and posture
i don't i don't think it was you i'm
telling you i don't think it's you
okay well again i just told you you were
weird but i'm not saying it's kraken
i'm saying i'm weird it's really mean it
is
it's you're weird you're not weird
kraken all right i won't i'll avoid you
i guess
i don't know man we're all gamers we're
pretty weird just in general yeah gamers
are like really unique
so like it's like a really uncommon
breed
like nobody games
anyway fredo sauce bye
[Laughter]
i love it i really don't think it's
bruce or kraken i i i don't
i think that banter was them [ __ ]
themselves and the imposters silently
watching and enjoying i think is what
happened there
um which is why everyone but those two
was so quiet it's because it's so easy
to just observe
i don't uh i don't think it's them
could be cracking i guess i i know bruce
better but i don't think it was bruce i
think bruce was just getting caught up
okay navigation let's go
i would really like to not die
that would be great boom
doing tasks doing tasks
getting my job done tasking around
okay
we gotta go [ __ ] storage bruff
hey dixon hey hey hey hey
oh that [ __ ] standoff was beautiful
okay
hey bud
why did kraken leave did you just leave
even though the o2 is right there dude
all right okay okay so i saw dave right
on top of it i knew it wasn't bruce oh
okay
killed him to you know silence them
forever what
i okay he was going to figure at you and
all of a sudden he's dead
no okay listen i i was with you diction
okay you saw me i went through storage
uh south up into navigation
and then i see k-town and dave standing
over the body just waiting there
and then they reported as soon as i
walked around the corner can i ask why
you left admin the minute that the admin
o2 things started going off you were
like i'm a piece and not do that
the admin o2 thing yeah we were an admin
you and i were doing a task i assume on
the wall and then you just [ __ ]
walked out when the
the a lot went off you just pieced i
guess i didn't notice that i don't
really do most of the emergencies i'll
be honest
i just do all the uh other tests okay i
i will i will say that
i was with cricut for a good bit of this
last round we didn't kill each other
and i did see him run up and i also did
very much see
dave right over the body so what do you
want to say
and carry over the body yeah both of
them
and it was somebody reported it too but
i didn't see him uh dave
hi yes hello benny what i came up
from the communications
where i was hiding to do the emergency
and then around the corner uh
i went to click on the emergency thing
and then someone behind me had killed
bruce
and i was trying to click on the
emergency and then i came out of it
because fredo got it and it's dave it's
there's
i'm 100 sure it's either kryken or kerry
because they were both back but there's
it's there
it's voting dave okay all right if it's
not david's kraken right
i mean no carry okay it is not kraken
i also like actually trust crack in here
you've done toss right next to me too
he was looking at both of them staring
at the body yeah
i feel pretty good about that
still another one [ __ ] left though
okay
i i feel like kraken's behavior has just
not been
sus you know like old mate crikey boy
has been doing things that makes sense
that's all i'm saying
i'm gonna do this quick no wrong one
idiot done
okay everybody please leave me alone so
i can just stay alive it takes up so
much of the [ __ ] screen you know
oh my gosh i'm so close i'm just i'm
just we're just almost done
okay all right okay
we're getting there
come on come on come on i just
um i still ain't seeing [ __ ] though
i would like it if a murderer would oh
run it away run it away run it away run
it away run it away
what are you doing kraken you suck [ __ ]
he's not even i keep blaming him even
though he hasn't done anything wrong
okay
that does that clear addiction it was
cracking
because now i'm scared of seeing two
people run next to each other because
that [ __ ] me before
you know oh that's convenient
just got locked in another room i love
that for me
all right i have one more task
in security but
oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god jesus
uh it's right i was with one the entire
time should you kill me it's gotta be
fair though
i don't know which one of you it is you
were with dickson and now you're not but
i don't know where fredo
freda where were you just now alana my
path was on the right side
and it wasn't nav was cracking with you
the entire i was
no you just got locked in another room
but
you just got i don't know which one of
you it is oh my [ __ ] god
what were you just doing this round
together we did the reactor together
big bringing the [ __ ] out of this right
now i'm not i'm really not
i said i reacted together at the
beginning of this round round one
we were doing tasks together as well
you're right you're right and i have not
seen fredo
[ __ ]
[Music]
other side that's the last the only time
i didn't see you and then dictionary
step
i mean yeah but i didn't see him on my
side either i don't know where he went
look
i fredo i i feel like i had just seen
diction and what makes
what what what no what makes frank and
suss is being an addiction but what
makes fredo sus is the fact that i've
seen cracking do tasks around me
multiple times and i ain't seen
fredo at all and there's just dead
bodies lining up around me
i mean i get that i wasn't anywhere near
you i was completely i want to pass over
and now
this round and last round
is just spinning a web of lies right now
that's not true i'm putting alfredo
i'm going to vote i have been with you
this whole round there cannot be this
many bodies
if it was me i think i have to
girlfriend i think i have to because i
haven't seen you i
have the crack of wisdom that i don't
know what to do
no no no no no no
no i think i have to i'm sorry fred
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
come on please please please
[Music]
please please crack it please stand up
[ __ ]
daddy yes oh my gosh
it makes me panic for alana right now
freaking out holy [ __ ] someone from like
falling off a cliff
i felt like i was about to murder one of
my kids i don't even have kids that i
oh thank god oh my god both hands over
lava and had to pick one of us to drop
jeez because kraken you did get locked
where i had just seen diction but then i
was positive you'd be doing tasks near
me so i was like i don't i can't account
for fredo at all
fredo i'm so sorry no no no holy [ __ ]
i waited to see if there was any benefit
of the doubt and then i tried to
pick away at that when uh when i got
caught on that kill i was like my one
mission is to throw all suspicion off of
you
so i wait it was close we almost got
there were you right there next to him
that was close
leaves foreign
[Laughter]
oh my gosh okay uh
storage let's [ __ ] go to storage
gonna go to storage go into storage
i'm gonna have to clip that round out
that one's gonna be a youtube video
that was [ __ ] nuts man
holy [ __ ] yeah okay i'll get there just
let me do this first
okay just let me [ __ ] all right and
then we'll go and we'll do this
nine four six nine three
done beautiful i did it
okay just a medium speed just a medium
speed
beautiful all right okay a couple of
people
hanging out in here
all right everybody go the separate ways
hey dave
hey dave hey dave dave dave
dave dave dave dave what the [ __ ] is
this dave
dave i'm gonna need you to [ __ ] off bro
okay okay well we're locked in here
we're locked in i think that
clears dave
i think dave dave good
by that logic
all right
well oh no alana died no
i was with her in med bay and i thought
she was going to kill me because the
doors closed behind us
oh yeah i thought town's body in
electrical i
thought bruce was occupied and thus was
safe suspicious i just found the body
so wait dave did you leave med bay and
she was still in there
no she she went over towards reactor and
i went towards admin
okay i was like if he's looking at cams
maybe i'm fine
not the case [ __ ] uh who was over in
that side of the ship the left side
that was bottom left lower engine that's
a lot yeah i was near your security
[ __ ]
like close to camps
yeah i did see two people once that's
also something i don't know who the
other one is on the admin table
yeah i was electrical i was like
rotating between
cams because ever since dixon caught me
on cams i was like all right [ __ ] it
i'll try and catch somebody on the
camera
oh okay that is what he was doing i've
been killed dude
i gotta work i've been killed twice
doing that by fredo by the way
right away no he killed me the exact
same way i've been on cam so i'm staying
the [ __ ] out of there i did a whole
right side route from top to bottom
um that's weird multiple i okay i've
passed multiple times
i was on the right side and i didn't see
you there okay well i mean andy saw me
at the beginning he saw me in comms he
did at the beginning he went down
towards coms and shields yep mm-hmm but
i don't know where he is now he was so
afraid
i just saw i just passed i think it was
tricking
in uh no you didn't pass you're actually
running right at me and we were in
cafeteria i was going to a task and
you're running at me i'm pretty sure
it's fredo
oh
like i don't think that was where the
deaths were guys
bruce just said he was at security and
alana went that way before she died and
no one else seems to have been there
like i said and he's not right lower
engine again
no he wasn't he wasn't again
hey carrie who got you how you doing
no i was bruce i'll make brucey green it
was
i snapped my [ __ ] head oh no
who's the other one andy oh no way
okay wow that i feel like became
actually pretty obvious in that round i
was like bruce manny got it
yeah it okay the second i heard bruce is
like hmm okay
did andy kill you well oh yeah just
straight up straight up neck i thought i
was okay because bruce actually was on
cams
um and i was like oh yeah he's just
[ __ ] he's all the cameras
he's just taking a look really oh
welcome was that you and electrical just
now yep welcome
how are you doing joining us they really
they should have
bruce let it let it oh my god he let it
slip
yeah no one noticed he was like
i found a body in electric am i muted no
i found a body in electrical
i found dixon's body in electrical did
you
and did she i saw bree bree on the far
right side pretty sure she's clear
i wasn't freaking out i was unless she
did
where an electrical was it like in the
far back of the room
like on the vent or killing baby always
yes
everybody dies no just like kind of in
the middle i guess i don't know just in
the back of the room
andy how did you get all the way to
elect
how did you get there yeah you just like
head straight there or like over here
yeah i was doing the water questions
storage and i went up to the far right
to do that
main thing or whatever and i came right
back down to go to electrical
and i saw fredo pass me i saw i was at
the party like the entire time
and yeah and it was youtube yeah then it
was youtube walking by me while i was in
there reikins had some weird pathing
this whole
game dave remember what you said about
bruce back to that previous round where
kraken said i was coming straight at him
because i came from admin and i was
working my way over
to medical and cracking all irrelevant
disregard all of this
dave please telepathically coming at you
remember what you said
why didn't you go to oxygen no it went
you like walked away from it
the wrong people because there were like
five people walking towards it
there weren't five people around us it
was just you and me at the time and
there was someone end up being in there
but you [ __ ]
you didn't even know what i was running
away from you because you were chasing
me at the whole beginning of the round
for what it's worth i saw a cracking in
the car bruce killed me sniping monkey
that's why i'm saying bruce is and i did
run
he did kill me that's why i want dave
too okay he killed me
i'm skipping a game because i was
fleeing for my life [ __ ] sake
they're wrong people the ones who were
killing i'm so
andy yes i quiet we should look at bruce
as well stick with me if you want to
talk about that
yesterday i don't i don't think with me
look at me bruce
look at me don't bruce shouldn't have
claimed that i was i'll look at you
fredo i'll look at you
look at me while you do it
my god that was that was andy reporting
is dirty
yeah true scum i was
uh but there's still sauce on him so
yeah bree was
really onto it with the yeah how do you
get there so yeah i know they both
brought like people brought up good
things and i'm like keep pressing that
stop arguing amongst yourselves you're
so close come on
oh boy well they're pretty close again
this is my first game playing with y'all
but i've noticed that bruce is pretty
quick
to uh want to skip
fredo did it look awful like they were
posing up for a double kill there
it looked like it might have been a
stack kill and then someone killed
uh kraken and andy are you [ __ ] kid
dude
we i'm the only one you all follow me
and i stood in a room with three other
people
and just wanted to like see where
everybody went and then i have to go
back to electrical i'm nowhere near
ending
i'm in electrical with kraken and he's
just standing there and it was [ __ ]
sus
yeah he's not even attacked
no no i'm
who was down there me you dave who was
it you did crack in fredo
can i defend myself for a second okay
literally i'm almost done all my tasks
the last thing i have is an electrical
and i'm like look i'm just going to
prove to everyone you don't need so i
wanna i'm gonna cut you off because we
have a minute we need to figure out who
the [ __ ] it is so like well we don't we
don't have to vote we don't have to vote
we need to talk about other stuff we
don't need to defend you
i think it's bruce because bruce always
says we have to vote and
suddenly we don't
i think it could be bruce because he's
not accusing me and that it's very
unlike him
[Laughter]
i haven't seen i haven't seen you the
entire time
in the first round i believe this to be
true it's true
i don't know it's so true
remember when dave [ __ ] up a couple of
rounds ago
i'm not gonna [ __ ] up this time i'm
taking the shot
this time
[Laughter]
i'm going to be very upset mr president
in the last five seconds kraken do you
want to defend yourself
what what okay
[ __ ] dave man bless him oh my god
what
[Laughter]
this is poppycock yeah
they oh man they're they're on to bruce
but not
i think they've been thrown around but
yeah
goddamn watching right now he's
literally waiting in a hallway for his
timer to go down
amazing he's not doing anything he can't
confirm pretty [ __ ] sauce bro
[Music]
all right found the body oh dave no
[ __ ] everybody it was uh thank god
[ __ ] all right that's us you killed the
president
probably it was uh top right the quarter
from weapons down to towards navigation
where was i trying i have been trying to
not kill dave the entire just so you
know like
i don't want to vote is that hard is
that what you said when you killed alana
in
k-town addiction
dave i can kill this one now we have to
vote
hold on hold on i'm bruce where were you
i was bottom right and shields
okay where were you i reported the body
yes i don't give a [ __ ] where were you
was between weapons and navigation
[ __ ] okay why didn't you come to the
reactor why didn't you and bruce only
made a reactor
what do you mean cricket doesn't do
tasks
i was getting my last task over there
not crying you mean you didn't know
because there's no reason for kraken to
call it if he's the second imposter
if the kill was happened happened on the
opposite side of reaction and he's just
not [ __ ] saying anything he's dead
silent
nobody's on stream there's two imposters
out there we have to vote we have to
vote but again
i was bottom right shields coming from
that area to go to reactor
and again oh man i mean who's in
the reactor right now is myself right
i've been waiting for father the whole
[ __ ] time
i was in the middle because farley and
andrew you've got to get rid of one of
these [ __ ] you guys you gotta
i was there you gotta get rid of one of
them that was you okay i'm voting bruce
i'm going farley
i speak for freya i think it's bria you
probably do because you're probably the
killer
yes notably andy didn't work
or say anything no he didn't get it in
so good luck losing guys
good luck losing everybody
adam dave i just want to say thank you
i just i just really want to thank you
for being right ed for standing up for
me
i left you and met me and i walked over
and then bruce [ __ ] killed me and
then he killed you
okay finally got brave
again i'm calling again because i don't
want to lose
i did all my asks let's talk some more
okay
i'm an admin just looking at the rooms
trying to find anybody venting
okay where have you been you were just
standing at the table krykin
no i went did my last task over by
weapons okay
well yeah i saw crack i saw cracking go
right it was the little switch
the for the switchboard like you
diverted power engine bria broke off
into electrical
yeah i went off into electrical um i had
one task left i'm worried they're going
to vote out crying
that's why i waited on it well i was
going to do it before but then i ran
into it well you started crying
a couple rounds ago and that's when he
was i think he was with someone else at
the time he was looking at me
he was staring okay it's not us too
so we gotta we gotta suss out who else
it is
i don't think it is it okay
you say that farley yeah
probably not you're really [ __ ] good
at this game and we've been attached to
the hip the entire time
like you've been together what were you
doing pretty much i was in admin
looking at the table like to see all the
rooms where people were come on oh easy
kill
you can do it yeah no i'm trying to see
if he's venting like the last game
no i'm saying you're an easy target to
kill i mean look we're really close to
finishing with tasks anyway so
we are i i think we don't have any info
we don't have any info on this so
we don't i'm suss of bria
and maybe andy yes definitely
everybody anyone who says you might be
suspicious okay no
no i want to help him
he said you're not suss and you yell at
him so okay
do we have any new information not
really
i have one task left okay everybody
seems to be
like their stories seem to be lining up
get it done get it done oh damn
it's like a spicy rub on the stick right
now and just chew right through it
i'm still saying what
what did that [ __ ] just say
let's talk about this can't talk still
here what the [ __ ]
hey he's talking about steak i came back
from the dead to just be like what's up
like a fun steak
he's talking about just a deliciously
seasoned steak i guess
medium rare sounds good okay okay that's
all my tossed oh no no i think i have
one more
this is a i mean i'll say it i'll say it
to the other round but it's
kind of unsporting to do this where all
four of you run together because there's
no way or
there's no way you're gonna lose that's
a super sweaty move
yeah yeah but i mean i understand not
wanting to die
like i get it but yeah well no no no but
wouldn't it work if he
uh if you sabotage yeah
it doesn't oh
oh beautiful it was like two tassers i
mean
that was one yeah but you guys stacked
the round previous you built you and
fredo
you guys are stacking the entire time
yeah i mean if you
if you find somebody in the first round
that's not killing you there's a double
kill
yeah i respect it i respect it we're
allowed to stack okay all right
[Music]
i'm gonna head out you guys sporting so
i'm gonna head quick who is me
i'm bouncing thank you everyone was
super fun um andy sauce is fun
i gotta take off too uh see y'all okay
all right friends that was fun i didn't
i was an apostle the whole time which is
like my ideal
situation uh i will clip out that round
that had fredo and kraken at the end i
think uh
we'll make a highlight of that that i'll
publish separately but um
yeah this was super fun thank you for
watching everyone bruce is raising money
for
st june right now if you want to go
check that out we can give him a raid i
guess
um but otherwise i'll see y'all next
time